okay so the topic of this video is the
process of translation or protein
synthesis so let's get started so here's
a karyotype now I've highlighted one of
the chromosome number tens here let's
zoom on in and when we do we kind of get
the idea what a gene is a gene is a
small section of our DNA it contains
instructions on how to build a specific
protein gene a would have instructions
to make a protein gene B instructions to
make another protein and we have
approximately 25,000 genes scattered
throughout our 46 chromosomes and so we
have a lot of instructions here on how
to make proteins and proteins are kind
of a big deal in our cells when we use
proteins in the making of our cells we
use proteins in our cells to do a
variety of cellular functions we use
proteins to build the tissue that forms
our body so understanding how proteins
may are made is crucial so when we talk
about protein synthesis it really
involves two processes the first being
transcription here is a piece of DNA
here let's do transcription and make RNA
and so we can review transcription and
remind us that an enzyme
there's my enzyme the animated scissors
the enzyme RNA polymerase will break
apart the double helix next the notes
say that messenger RNA nucleotides will
match well let's go ahead and do
transcription from left to right with
the top series of letters notice how
there's an a because we're doing
transcription au matches next would be a
a next is a a for adenine next is a G
for guanine another G next is a C for
cytosine and from left to right as we
continue transcription here
transcription is the process of making
RNA we're using our DNA
to make RNA once we're done with this
then the mRNA will detach and move over
to a ribosome that's transcription and
don't forget the double helix then
recombines so after transcription is
finished next comes the process of
translation that's the actual job the
ribosome does to make a protein and when
we combine the two this is what is known
as the central dogma of biology it's a
core fundamental concept where how the
language of DNA is turned into RNA
through transcription and then the
language of RNA is translated into the
ribosome building a protein and so these
are complementary processes that
ultimately lead to the formation of a
protein let's talk about this some more
so here's the messenger RNA that we just
created this messenger RNA will exit the
nucleus and go into the cytoplasm of a
cell and once it's in the cytoplasm the
messenger RNA will arrive at a ribosome
and now the process of translation can
begin the ribosome is gonna read that
mRNA and let's talk about how that
happens so you might have seen a picture
like this in biology class this is
called the genetic code and you see all
those three letter sequences uuu c cg a
ag these are what are called codons
these are three messenger RNA
nucleotides and through a lot of
research by some wonderful scientists we
were able to figure out that these
sequences we call those three letter
sequences of code on these sequences
these codons here correspond to the
twenty known amino acids notice the word
leucine and serine and prolene and
histidine these are the amino acids and
so what happens is when the mRNA goes to
a ribosome the ribosome will read these
sequences three letters at a time and
what happens next is the transfer RNA
will deliver the proper amino acid well
how does this work well what if the
ribosome reads the codon ACU well the a
the first letter is an A so the a is in
that row the second letter is a C so the
C is in that column they overlap in that
red box let's find ACU what this means
if the ribosome reads a see you then
transfer RNA will deliver the amino acid
called threonine over to the ribosome
well what if the ribosome reads the
codon CAC well if the first letter is a
seed somewhere in this row here the
second letter is an
it's in this column they overlap right
there in that red box so there's CAC
what that means is transfer RNA will
deliver the amino acid histidine to the
ribosome
well how does the ribosome know when to
even start creating a protein because
when we find the codon Aug it's a
special code on to the right of Aug is
the word methionine methionine is one of
the amino acids but underneath the word
Matheny that says start codon there's an
actual start sequence that turns on the
ribosome when a ribosome encounters the
sequence Aug that starts the process of
translation transfer RNA will also
deliver amino acids called methionine so
how does a ribosome know when the
protein is finished well not only is
there a start codon to start translation
but there are there's a there are stop
codons as well there's actually three of
them now any one of these three will
stop the process and kind of deactivate
the ribosome but it's kind of I think
it's kind of interesting that there are
chemical signals to start the process of
translation and chemical signals to end
the process as well let's see how that
works next so when we look at the
process of translation this is the
actual process where the ribosome will
create a protein and first of all here
comes our messenger RNA it's arrived at
the ribosome notice that transcription
has just ended and what happens next is
the ribosome will read the codons once
it encounters Aug and I've highlighted
Aug right there in red so right now
nothing's really happening the ribosome
hasn't come to Aug yet but now it has
now the ribosomes at Aug and so the
ribosome the Aug will turn on the
ribosome and start the sequence and then
transfer RNA will deliver the proper
amino acid and we use the
chart right here to figure out what's
the proper amino acid we look up Aug Aug
on the chart yes it's a start codon but
it's also notice to the right of Aug is
the word methionine transfer RNA should
deliver methionine and in my animation
here comes this weirdly shaped object
that's transfer RNA it's carrying an
orange circle named methionine but how
does the ribosome know that this is the
right amino acid turns out there's a
hidden secret on T RNA tRNA actually has
three nucleotides itself called the
anticodon they're gonna drop out of the
tRNA right now watch what happens watch
the tRNA three to one on tRNA are three
nucleotides as well notice this is what
we call the anticodon anti is a prefix
that means opposite anticodon means
opposite the codon you a see that's
opposite of Aug because they are all
three accurate opposites this is the
safety method that prevents the delivery
of the wrong amino acid the anticodon in
the codon match and because they match
that is the chemical signal that we have
the proper amino acid so now the
ribosomal move to the next codon
highlighted red CCA the ribosome is
moved to the next codon well we get out
the chart we find CCA on the chart and
and we see the word prolene highlighted
the ribosome wants prolene next and it
is the job of tRNA to deliver prolene
now how does the ribosome know that it
has the proper amino acid notice the
anticodon that I just highlighted TG you
notice how that is a perfect match that
is opposite of CCA because the sequences
match we have the proper amino acid
the first tRNA will break away and now
we move down to the next codon and one
by one amino acids get linked together
Metheny links to prolene I've gone ahead
and highlighted the next codon GGA the
ribosome will move down to the GGA codon
and when we look at the chart we find
GGA and next to GGA is the word glycine
so tRNA should deliver glycine next well
my animation here comes tRNA oh no it's
not carrying glycine that's the wrong
amino acid we want a glycine if cysteine
is allowed to be delivered we would have
a improperly constructed protein which
would take on the wrong shape when it
twists and folds and wraps and very well
we could have a person with a perhaps a
very serious genetic disorder so this
process needs to be perfect we cannot
allow the delivery of that wrong amino
acid ask yourself does the anticodon
that I just highlighted does it match
the codon in red I hope you realize they
don't match we have an improper match
here because they don't match the entire
tRNA sequence will be removed that
allows the proper tRNA to enter by the
way can you predict what the proper
anticodon will be what's the entire
opposite of GG and red there here comes
tRNA with the anticodon of CC you notice
how the CCU anticodon is a perfect match
for the GG a codon because the entire
sequence of the anticodon and codon
because they match this is the proper
amino acid so the ribosome can hold onto
to T RNAs at the time the one that's
been sitting there for a moment will
break away and notice how the amino
acids are being chained together well
let's focus on the next coda and you see
gee the ribosome will move down to the
next codon you see G when we look at
when we look on our chart here we find
ucg and that's the amino acid serine we
want serine next who's gonna deliver
serine that would be tRNA
oh no that's not serine that's the wrong
amino acid we don't want prolene
if this wrong amino acid is allowed to
be delivered we would have an improperly
built protein which could be devastating
to our health here this process has to
be perfect we cannot allow that prolene
to be delivered does the anticodon right
now does it match the codon almost
almost notice how the second G and C are
a match and notice how the third C and G
are match but not the first two the
anticodon is almost a match for this
codon but it is still an improper match
because of that this entire tRNA will be
removed that will look that will provide
area for the proper one here comes the
proper amino acid ask yourself does the
AGC anticodon does that match with the
ucg codon we have a proper match and so
that is how we know we have the right
amino acid the ribosome can hold on to
two tRNAs at a time the one that's been
sitting there for a moment will break
away let's focus on the next codon the
next codon is guu the ribosome moves to
GG uu we find GU you on the chart Guu is
the codon for the amino acid valine we
want valine next so the codon GU you can
you predict what the proper anticodon
sequence will be what's opposite GU you
I hope you realize that's CAA
here comes tRNA notice how it has the
CAA anticodon that's perfectly that will
perfectly match the guu codon because we
have a match that means tRNA is carrying
the proper amino acid so the other tra
tRNA that's been sitting
for a moment can now break away and we
can focus on the next coat on the next
coat on being you a a the ribosome will
move down to you a a we look on the
chart we find you a a look at that it's
a stop codon
there's no amino acid to deliver the
process is now over and so translation
will end when one of the stop codons is
reached and so what happens next is the
tRNA has broken away the ribosome
actually breaks apart and the mRNA can
actually go back into the nucleus where
it's broken down and reused what we're
left with is a chain of amino acids a
polypeptide which will then become a
protein that's the act known as
translation so here's a practice problem
I want you to solve if I give you the
DNA sequence GGA you should be able to
fill in those three question marks pause
the video I'm gonna go over the answers
in 3 2 1
so if the code is if the DNA code is GGA
perform transcription and turn that into
the mRNA codon and when you do I hope
you said CCU ok well if you know the
codon is CCU the anti or opposite codon
the anticodon would be GGA ok GGA that's
glycine right no what do you mean no
there's GGA on the chart GGA says
glycine if you thought the answer was
glycine though here's a very common
mistake that I see every year remember
what is the ribosome reading the
ribosome is reading the mRNA sequence
and so that's what you have to remember
you have to look up the mRNA in this
case it would be CCU if you look up CCU
you will get the proper amino acid
prolene let's do another one of those
okay so in this example I'm gonna give
you the messenger RNA
AAG pause the video and try to figure
out the three question marks I'm gonna
go over the answers in three two one
so if the mRNA codon is a AG can you
predict what DNA letters would have
created that and I hope you said TTC
alright so if the codon is Aug what's
the opposite codon what's the anticodon
what's opposite a AG and that would be
you you see so then we go to the chart
what amino acid fits in that question
mark box I hope you said lysine why
lysine because we remember that we have
to look up the messenger RNA the
ribosome reads messenger RNA if you
thought the answer was phenyl alanine
then you mistakenly looked up you you
see the tRNA and you have to remind
yourself always used the messenger RNA
on this chart okay now these three
questions are a little lengthier pause
the video try to answer these I'm gonna
go over the answers in three two one
so question one in order list the amino
acids that will be delivered to this
ribosome I hope you ignored that codon
right there because we don't start until
we get to Aug we look up Aug on the
chart and it's the start codon not only
that but tRNA will deliver our first
amino acid methionine so imagine the
ribosome was moved to C c/g
we look up C c/g tRNA should deliver the
amino acid prolene ii imagine the
ribosome has now moved to a GU we look
up a GU on the chart tRNA should deliver
the amino acid serine third imagine the
ribosome moves to the codon CCA we look
up CCA on the chart tRNA should deliver
the amino acid prolene fourth
imagine the ribosome moves the next
codon GGA
we find GGA on the chart there it is
tRNA should deliver the amino acid
glycine v imagine the ribosome moves to
the next codon you see you we look up
you see you on the chart there it is
and so tRNA should deliver the amino
acid serine sixth and then imagine the
ribosome moves to this codon UGA UGA is
a stop codon and so we're done there's
the answer to question number one well
number two what is the anticodon of aug
I'm just circled the codon Aug what's
the anticodon of that that would be UAC
and then question 3 when finished
how many amino acids in size is this
protein well look at your answer to
number one you can see there are six
amino acids that make up this finished
protein so there you have it the process
known as translation so if you're in my
class pause the video try to answer some
of these questions and I'm happy to try
to check your answers before school or
after school thanks for watching